hey it's Friday and it's time for
another movie your retrospective doing
another old one today you guys seem to
like a Martin that we did last week so
this week we're gonna do sort of uh I
guess I'd call it a cult classic
it's a weird movie even though it's kind
of like and it's kind of a weird thing
to say but it's almost like a forgotten
cult classic yeah I like this movie I
did it was a weird movie because it's
like a low-budget movie done really well
yeah it's also kind of got a really high
budget for a low-budget movie it's a
weird it is it is a very weird just yeah
yeah and it's British which I like the
British know how to make a good
low-budget movie you know it's kinda
like what they did with Star Wars a new
hope and what's funny is that a lot of
that the guys that worked on a new hope
also did this one so yeah it does kind
of have a weird feel to it that I think
you guys will enjoy yeah it's kind of
like it has a strange pedigree this was
it came out in 1985 it's called life
force I was directed by tobe Hooper who
was an American obviously but he's
probably best known for Texas Chainsaw
Massacre obviously but a few years prior
to this he had actually done poltergeist
even though Steven Spielberg is usually
credited with poltergeist but I think
tobe Hooper actually sort of kind of
directed it but you know there's still a
lot of controversy there so this is
almost like sort of like tobe Hooper
being given a whole [ __ ] ton of money
yeah to do pretty much whatever he
wanted any heat what he wanted to do was
like a B picture or like a hammer movie
he essentially yes sort of and it's
being made by cannon and cannon yeah
normally known for really cheap like
Chuck Norris Chuck our ass movies Sly
Stallone I think they did over the day
and that Cary 80s went into electric
Boogaloo that might have been canon -
yeah I mean you know you don't watch
canon for heavy you know the
Shakespearean style entertainment you
know what I mean exactly this is just
you know let's get Jay mez what's
potential a Stallone flick in their past
Aquila
it's that kind of stuff let's watch
Chuck Norris and his beard the Shayan
whole villages yeah it's not an it
seemed like most of it was marketed
towards teenage boys hacks
a lot of it you know which that's cool
so if you were growing up in the 80s you
know what a candy flick is yeah but I
guess what Canon wanted to do they sort
of wanted to play with the big boys you
know because they'd made quite a lot of
money like making these cheap knockoff
action movies and I think they wanted
you know by the time the mid 80s rolled
around they wanted more respect yeah so
life force was supposed to be their kind
of entry into yeah this was a big-budget
Hollywood yeah this is their
breakthrough film yeah they're gonna
which you know it didn't quite work out
like that but not flat it did it
Flockhart hard but it shouldn't have
them no it's such an interesting
experience because like I said tobe
Hooper directed a very respected
director also they gave him 25 million
dollars yeah and told him pretty much
you can do whatever you want one of the
writers was now this was based on a book
by Colin Wilson called the space
vampires yeah
now that was originally what they were
gonna call the movie but then it was
like no we can't call it that because we
wanted to class up the joint
yeah so let's call it lifeforce instead
which it sounds like which is the
funniest thing cuz you're like two
seconds into the movie and the credits
it says based on the book vampires yeah
I was like Oh wah wah wah wah you should
have shown that if you can change the
title don't show just show it really
really small but yeah so one of the
writers of the screenplay was Dan
O'Bannon who obviously wrote alien and
also Return of the Living Dead it's
almost kind of like those you things
combined yeah like to make this movie
because it's like yeah it's like all
those I'm watching this [ __ ] that's
sucking hilarious it's it's a vampire
movie in space okay I'm some of its in
space yes of its in space but the way it
plays out you start off you're kinda
watching alien and then all of a sudden
you're watching kinda like vampire movie
and then there's this really cute naked
chick running around and then you're
watching Gorgo with miniatures of London
baseball
then you're watching neither living-dead
with a bunch of vampires zombies zombies
excuse me and then you have Ghostbusters
with a bunch of it's just it's just
everything at once it's in a way it
should have been a [ __ ] show it's hard
to follow the script in a certain way
characters show up they seem important
they're kind of important for a while
and then you never see him again
replaced by other characters
it's just weird it's a weird flip but I
thoroughly enjoyed it I thoroughly
enjoyed the way it looked and the way it
felt it was fun fun to watch like you
said it's almost like I don't know a
bunch of movies - yeah it's like one of
the weirdest things we've ever reviewed
because now I I don't remember if I saw
this back in the day I probably did
because I remember the naked chick
running around and I kind of remember
some stuff about it so I must have seen
it on cable probably back in the 80s
yeah but I hadn't seen it since then and
then I kept hearing about it like some
of our other movie review channels we
watched like Oliver's retrospectives and
Brendan tunneled and they revisited this
movie and I was like God you know I
haven't seen that a long time I wonder
is that any good and then it came up on
to be a couple weeks ago yeah you watch
it for free on tube yes I'm a-gonna
blu-ray copy of this though yeah it's
actually good enough to haul it's cool
flick so I said man we should do a
review of that because I haven't said
cuz I really didn't remember anything
about it and it's just like you said in
a way on paper it sounds amazing yeah
but it also sounds like a [ __ ] show it
should have been even should've been an
even shittier [ __ ] show because a script
like this and what's happening the
things that happen in this movie are
normally executed with really low
budgets yeah special effects in this
case it's high budget special effects
yeah it looks pretty good he's pretty
good especially for the day I mean the
alien shots look like something on par
with HR Geiger's aliens yeah scenes of
that in certain ways the miniature shots
of London getting screwed up looked like
something there good mattress and it's
weird you know alien ships are attacking
and weird crap like that it's like
something kind of like out of Gorgo
without that I think you have a bunch of
Night of the Living Dead zombies and
then there's something weird about it
where you kind of get this day of the
Triffids type feel remember that flick
kind of like that the British have a
certain way of doing things I got a very
hammer yeah Quatermass in the pit vibe
yeah that's the first thing I thought of
and when I went and read some other
reviews I was like oh so I wasn't wrong
because a bunch of people came here to
feel like Ghostbusters you in New York's
being attacked by ghosts yes yeah this
one right it's the Hat it had that vibe
and I I think somebody from Ghostbusters
but actually think they borrowed some
stuff from Ghostbusters I would think
they borrowed some stuff from a lot of
how a zoo you know and yeah with all the
like marshmallow man in this case they
replaced it with zombies you know this
is I mean I actually thoroughly enjoyed
this movie though I remember seeing it
as he young you know when I was young
yeah yeah 20s and looking at it and just
I was kind of nonplussed and not that
interested at the time but we were just
being inundated by high budget movies
that were kind of like this yeah so this
just seemed to be one of the other ones
I really didn't pay much I didn't really
remember it I remember that naked chick
how can you forget that well that's what
I mean that I think when you talk about
life force it seems like Matilda May
yeah who's the woman is this hottie
yes Ginny but hottie she walks around
like naked most of this movie and I
think that's pretty much the only thing
people that haven't seen it in a long
time I mean it is very very 80s that was
like 80 standards of beauty she was a
French model out of fashion model but
you know like a fashion model that guys
with like straight guys would like you
know yeah nowadays you know they put
like some girl on there with some
badonkadonk you know no man she says
she's kind of scanning by today's
standards but she was cute yeah and that
was the draw you know yeah guys are
gonna sit there yeah they're like okay
I'll see ya home movie watching male the
may walk it around with her titties you
got Patrick Stewart in it yeah Patrick
series this is a man on screen this and
very funny this is something after his
Matilda main nakedness like a distant
second for things this movie is
remembered for some all-star cast is
Patrick Stewart is in this briefly and
he plays like the head of an insane
asylum right yeah yeah and he actually
it's kind of a complicated thing to get
into yeah he's sort of kisses Steve
Railsback yeah
there's not a gay body position the guy
kisses him yeah yeah so but Patrick
Stewart likes to joke that that was his
first onscreen kiss take us out Magister
it was always the same age he looked
exactly the same at motherfuckas 45 in 8
1985 yeah he looked he like he was 45
for his whole life
he just came out of the womb looking
like that some people are like that
still looks like that
far far seconds I mean I haven't seen
him recently do you know years ago he
still look like he's 40 yeah you look
it's like he got to a particular age is
just stayed there yeah
the same thing happened to Who am I
thinking of John Carradine yeah is it
John Carradine that is I think good yeah
he always looked like that like I saw
there was a really really really old
movie that he was in like something
shark at Prisoner of Shark Island or
whatever where he looked super young in
that but then every movie I said I'm in
subsequently he was just like it was
like he went from 30 to like 60 in that
state yeah and then he just stayed look
at also exteriors oh she's got that
British guy in there that if you saw
Clockwork Orange Jews the guy who
grabbed at us is not to punched out what
I grabbed him smacked him on yes it was
like some yeah that was like his
guidance counselor yes cut type of thing
or his paw games yeah gay games yeah
that guy was in that game there's really
like there's a lot of like big British
actors like Finley is in this this is
one American guy Peter Firth is in it we
don't know who he is
well it's one American guy that we don't
know who he is the throws of Steve
Railsback yeah
[ __ ] dinner movies yeah he's from Texas
he's gonna shed ton of movies the sad
thing about this like you said I mean
1985 this was only like a year after
Ghostbusters came out I think cocoon
came out the same year as this kind of
whipped its ass so there was a lot of
this sort of I hesitate to call this a
sci-fi movie although it does have side
where in elements yeah it's kind of all
over the place damn circus it is that's
good though but it's a good circus yeah
like it shouldn't work aged very well
for you know what it is the movie -
another thing I loved about the movie is
that it delivered instantly as soon as
you start seeing the movie this [ __ ] to
look at and there's not a single boring
frame in this [ __ ] movie yeah there
is always some there's always some the
look at gray market even though it's on
just British soldiers and kind of the
old 80's or 80s uniforms with styrol
machine guns and just you know cool [ __ ]
British guys being British as [ __ ] it's
just it's got everything you see you
want to see in a movie like this well
and it's funny because I know I think
the original cut was quite a bit longer
but even at 128 minutes or whatever this
is it might be a little bit shorter than
that it actually it never drags there
are no slow parts now it pretty much at
the beginning you're in the ship and
it's like within two or three minutes
they're like oh we found this ship and
there's like it's all it was on fire
there's all this [ __ ] going on you know
cuz all this crew goes up in a space
shuttle and they find this ship that
looks like they said they based it on an
artichoke yeah it look kind of like an
umbrella backwards umbrella flying at
yeah it looked very it looked organic
kind of Danny like an org organics
patient any line had a big love child
with a vampire bat on top of a umbrella
flying backwards kind of like that thing
from 2001 a Space Odyssey with a
discovery and has big long spaceship but
it was made by aliens that's kind of the
cool thing about it - and then when they
go inside the ship I mean the shots in
there are this I mean the way when they
first go in there and there's like all
those like bat creatures hang in there
but it's like all the weird [ __ ] in the
back the aliens look like bats vampire
and the existence of these things they
definitely been [ __ ] with humans for a
long time created the legends of
vampires
yeah they got into it somehow sounds
legit not everything is really clear to
me with this movie I believe I was
drinking some Keela at the time we were
watching no not you I think I was so I
was just rolling with it I wasn't trying
to analyze the script it's not that kind
of movie yeah I mean it's one where it
is taking itself seriously all right
yeah if you don't take it that seriously
cuz it's cool to look at its kind of
movie you could just put on the video
system at a nightclub and just roll it
on repeat and it would just be a good
background visual yeah
first a lot of the shots every shot is
cool to look at so you could yeah yeah
and like I said you know the there's a
woman walk around naked most yeah
there's like you know there's all the
bats there's oh and I forgot to mention
to probably my favorite effect in this
other than the infamous scene where the
vampire like sucks all the ticks all the
blood out of you know looks all your
life force energy yeah well no I mean
sucks all the blood out and then turns
introduce a blood one a blood woman yeah
and it falls on the ground there's like
no reason for that to happen but it was
hi reminded me of something out of
Dracula you know like where you know
track that turns into a pile of rats and
falls to the ground it was just kind of
like an effect that they put in there
cuz they're like this will look really
cool we don't really you know and it did
look really cool for you but on him one
of my favorite but other than that my
favorite effect in this is what the
corpses look like after Matilda May she
doesn't have a name in the movie she's
just called space girl yeah in the
credits space girl yeah she's a vampire
but they're like psychic vampires they
basically suck out your lego G yeah your
soul or whatever you want to close
involved somehow
remember that cuz yeah it did things
with blood and being you could get all
your energy somehow sucked out of you
and if the body wasn't destroyed you'd
come back as a vampire it didn't grab
yeah it did spread it did spread it just
it wasn't so biological yes story it was
more energy based yeah cool but I really
liked the corpses after you know after
they had their all their psychic energy
sucked out those animatronics yeah
looked really
good yeah they were you know I mean they
weren't quite as good what you could to
do today well no of course 1985 19-4 the
time they looked really for 1985 you
look at it now and you go yeah they're
puppets but you know what [ __ ] it I'm a
roll with it that cool
they really are creepy looking puppets
yeah and that kind of adds to the charm
of this movie I think it's aged well I
think so too it's not that kind of movie
to where you're totally convinced by the
special effects but that you're not
going into this movie with that yeah
you're going into this movie that it's
it's an art form yeah that's definitely
what it is just appreciate in for an arc
seems like and I was talking to somebody
on the YouTube about this it's kind of a
shame how movies like this I guess it
sort of got a small cult following now
yeah now like I said this cost twenty
five million dollars to make they gave
it to tobe Hooper it only made about
eleven and a half million
it really really lost its out it's been
around for a long time it's probably
actually made that money back I'm pretty
sure just DVD VHS HBO and Cinemax cable
you know that it's probably made its
money back up but the thing is is Canon
Studios doesn't exist anymore so he
doesn't know who owns the rights to the
movie yeah I don't know either although
it got some decent reviews when it came
out yeah I think a lot of maybe
audiences didn't really know what to
make of it because like I said it's
really not it's not exactly a sci-fi
movie it's not exactly a horror movie I
mean it just has so much going on like I
said from the beginning it seems like a
sci-fi and then it's like a hammer movie
and then it's like a big like then it's
like a zombie but like a zombie
apocalypse type of movie and then you
said it's got like Ghostbuster elements
at the end it's like the whole city
getting destroyed and like all these
people getting zombified and all this
other kind of [ __ ] so it's like it's
super entertaining it doesn't make a
huge amount of sense but if it's
entertaining who gives a [ __ ] yeah you
know what I mean
it looks cool the story's cool I should
say the guy that wrote the book the
space vampires dude you called the book
the space vampires okay so I'm not sure
how much of your judgment I could trust
he hated this movie he hated the movie
he thought he pretty much basically said
he didn't come out and say it but he
pretty much implied that he thought this
was like the worst movie add up to
ever made of anyone's novel ever yeah
yeah I haven't read the novel so I don't
know I don't know how different the book
is I don't think it's all that different
I think all they did in the movie was
that they updated it so it was like the
space shuttle program because that was
you know going on at the time so they
wanted to make it seem now I think that
the novel was set in the future whereas
the movie is set in the present day yeah
except you know we have better
technology than we had in 1985 but it's
not so much that you know that it seems
like the Future III had a case just like
present-day I thought that they were
trying to you know put it a few years
into the future because they you have
some pretty cool stuff on space shuttles
and didn't England have a space shuttle
yeah England had a space notion yeah it
was Churchill the Churchill yeah yeah
yeah it was like yeah it was like um US
UK your uh you know a joint exploration
mission the movie came out what was it
81
85 85 yeah 85 I mean a lot of stuff was
coming out at that time and a lot of
really good stuff had already come out
yeah the competition was probably pretty
stiff for this movie oh yeah
85 you know wasn't the 70 so you
probably didn't have as many people in
the theater smoking pot before they with
yeah yeah that helped a lot of movies
you know I mean that covered up a lot of
crazy plot point the plot holes and
weird scripts you know it means like the
black hole you don't need a spacesuit to
be outside the black hole yeah okay yeah
[Laughter]
yeah but yeah we'll never forgive the
black hole's director for allowing the
actors to say we don't want to wear the
spacesuits
they're so constricted so constrict we
don't want to wear this fear just get a
flat okay do they do the space seizures
out yeah no one will notice that we're
gonna be too high to know that really
ruined that movie although I see you out
of it yeah well I didn't notice it as a
kid because I think I saw it about 110
okay 10 11 or something didn't really
give a [ __ ] you know when I was 10 or 11
but as an adult I really liked the rest
of the movie yeah then I skip
I've seen in the black corn you're like
why the [ __ ] did they do that you know
idiot yeah that's the thing it's like oh
yeah I'm not one of those people that's
gonna like nitpick every little detail
but something that's so obvious I mean
everybody knows that you need a
spacesuit in a vase whether or not
you're near the black hole or not I mean
you could have gotten away with it in
the 50s yeah when everybody's like oh it
has air let's just take our helmets up
let's walk around on the outside of the
spaceship yeah I think they were trying
to say well it's me maybe we're slightly
in the dementia it's in an oxygen pocket
yeah big huge oxygen pocket around the
black hole right but but yeah but like I
said the thing about life force is that
it doesn't have anything that stands out
to me like you know it's a story about
space vampires so you can't be too you
know hard on it
because you're already yeah suspending
your disbelief and really there's
nothing in there that stood out to me is
like oh the you know what I mean it was
go like that go you I just rolled with
it I was like yeah okay that's that's
cool she's sucking out the must if
they're soaking up the souls and it must
have failed by a combination of stuff
one it's a foreign movie two probably
had something do with the timing of the
release yeah and the way the audiences
were at the time they may have been kind
of sick of these to this type of movie
at that time yeah and probably wasn't in
the theater for very long so it was
probably taken out before it could get
an audience that happened yeah this like
I said and I was talking to somebody on
YouTube others today's but maybe made
him pull it so they could get their
movie in it another movie came out
something like that like you know I was
talking about how sometimes movies like
this that are sort of off the wall I
think sometimes it takes them time it's
the word to get out find their audience
like you know what I mean I think if
people you know people are gonna go to
the theater and see somebody who's gonna
make zillions of dollars it usually has
to be pretty pretty crowd-pleasing
yeah I think something that's a little
bit challenging or weird or something
well think about this [ __ ] they said
well people tend to remember it fondly
later on later on but not at the time
but not at the time at the time there's
a lot of the time they're looking at it
wait a minute hold on this is alien and
this is a vampire movie and a mermaid
and it's a Hammer horror movie and it's
a and it's a Samba movie and its
ghostbusters
and it's Gorgo you know a minute and
it's war the world cuz yeah a lot ago
there was a lot I think it just kind of
overwhelmed with the sensibilities of
kind of square as people at 85 and they
were probably said it's hard it's hard
to get him to swallow everything now you
could get a dude like Arnold
Schwarzenegger get him to believe crazy
[ __ ] because you didn't take that
seriously from right but this was
obviously a serious yeah yeah it wasn't
like a bit like obviously a b-movie it
looked slick yeah it looked pretty much
as good as you know everything else that
came out of that job yeah you know what
I mean so it wasn't obviously like oh
this is just a shitty stupid like direct
to VHS if I trying to be everything at
once yes so it didn't it didn't and it
didn't attract everyone at once yeah
well it had been a straight-up vampire
movie made it done better and yes
straight-up alien movie it probably
would have done would it yeah I feel
across genre movies are always a hard
sell yeah I think that's what happened
and that's definitely what this is I'm
not even like I said I'm not even sure
what genre this is exactly was it
adventure events sci-fi adventure I
guess more like I said it seemed very
much like a Quatermass like a later
hammer crossover sci-fi I'm saying also
you know a disaster film like a 70s
disaster film so yeah so there was a lot
of elements going on that I think people
couldn't really get a handle on what is
this like it's go oh and now they're
zombies what the [ __ ] you so much
happened in it I'm not even totally sure
if if the script made sense it convinced
me that it made sense but I'd have to
sort of me I'd have to see it again I
was under the impression that it made
sense well question what happen
fairly I mean these the the naked people
that we're in the cubes yeah they were
the aliens now they now they had been
around for a really long time and they
basically just went from planet to
planet and sucked everybody's Souls out
that's like their food instead of blood
they were like vampires but like psychic
vampires that's all yeah I don't know
I'm just talking
the way the story unfolded yeah I was
under the impression that it was making
sense yeah I think largely made sense
yeah I mean if you kind of pay attention
I'm enjoying it like I'm not sure how
the zombies factored in
I think the energy I was talking about
yeah where did [ __ ] like that okay do
you know why I think the zombies were
there because they couldn't afford to
make a bunch of the dessicated looking
corpses so they just said well [ __ ] it
we'll just do generic zombies cuz either
like for all the extras and stuff or
they could argue that maybe the vampires
didn't suck out all of their life for us
just part of it and then that made you
kind of look like I didn't question it
at the time oh yeah next thing I know
we're in the zombie apocalypse
yeah sure where they came from next
thing you know I didn't know if I missed
something I didn't dare I'm just like
okay well yeah that's what I mean I
guess it's one of those things for you
yeah alright we're doing this now then
there's souls going through it like out
of ghostbusters yeah ghosts souls come
on ya know what it was I'm just going
alright okay I can roll with that that
looks cool kinda like some Italians
would do all right but I was just
enjoying it you know I'd like to see it
again yeah but that's the thing it's
like as I said this was tobe Hooper's
this was his first movie he got a
three-picture deal with canon you know
cuz canon was like hey class up the Joe
the joint Toby so he made this and it
was a flop yeah but he still had to make
two more movies for them
so he made invaders from Mars Oh
actually that's good I really like that
it's a remake from an old yeah yeah I
remember liking it yeah it likes you too
and Texas Chainsaw Massacre too that's
that's definitely which is what it's
it's a horror comedy yeah a lot of plan
first like it but yeah it's it's a lot
of fun I ended up on a lot of Skinny
Puppy albums yeah any puppy songs you
ever sampling from I first saw it at a
slumber party and it was like it's a
hell of a lot of fun that I like to get
both Danis not presented chewing the
scenery like crazy yeah I didn't rise
that was canon yeah I didn't either
actually so canon did kind of improve a
little bit yeah cuz I don't remember
those movies being bad I remember them
being pretty good yeah so they you know
their heart was in the right place they
knew what they were doing is just
audience weren't ready to think I'm with
him on that I think canon did
Deathwish movies to today probably
probably three and what the Italians did
a Deathwish movie to I don't know if
they did that with Canon but one of the
death wishes it movies was basically
like a an absurd shoot him up you know
yeah I mean style shoot him up in it
even had little Charlie Charlie Bronson
little Charlie Charlie he's like five
four did you know that you just had that
angry looking face look like it should
be on a mole or something like little
gopher face you know go for fear with
his mustache crackly voice a little
bitty dude that was 70s you know what I
mean you didn't have to take your shirt
off in the seventies oh well some people
didn't lady but later Cheston Chaston
yeah dude put his shirt back on but he's
like but I wanted to take my shirt off
yeah one yeah but yeah so seriously if
you are into cuz this like I said this
is one that's a little bit under the
radar I only remembered it because I saw
it on a couple of other review shows and
I wanted to revisit it because I hadn't
seen it in so long so if you're into
kind of weird cross-genre vampire sci-fi
yeah I give it to Zhaan two thumbs up
stuff with naked chicks in it and and
you're into like British movies too like
you know yeah then you would probably
really dig I only got two thumbs and
I'll give them both thumbs up on this
what about you two thumbs up or just
want them oh no I definitely gave it two
thumbs I enjoyed the hell out of it yeah
and I don't think that was just the
liquor talking
no I was good I liked it I want to see
you again yeah but yeah so as of this
recording it's actually on to B so you
can go watch it for free if you would
like to buy it on blu-ray do whatever
you want I don't care but yeah but yeah
it's a good movie and I definitely
recommend it and that will do it for
this installment of our movie
retrospective remember if you like the
show to like share subscribe on all your
social media if you'd like to
financially support the show you can
check out our patreon page at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast or
you can go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation also remember to check
out our new t-shirt designs on our
Zazzle store which is
wwsz soul comm / 13 o'clock
be sure to check out our regular
episodes which come out every Tuesday
and our movie retrospectives which come
out every Friday we will see you next
time bye